dankeschön - am kommenden sonntag ist
der vierte sonntag nach ostern kantate
und das heißt wir sind nach systematik
und zählung der christlichen kirchen
hierzulande noch in der osterzeit die
übrigens wissen pfingsten gilt und die
insofern ist es auch sprachlich völlig
okay dass die bundesregierung an diesem
donnerstag in den bundestag einbringen
das sogenannte oster paket und in diesem
kloster paket stecken in drei
gesetzentwürfe die sich beschäftigen mit
dem schnelleren ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien das dringlich nötig ist wissen
wir es gibt viele gute gründe dafür da
voranzukommen die frage ist nur ob die
schönen pläne alle auch aufgehen darüber
wird der bundestag gleich gut 70 minuten
75 minuten diskutieren ab 9 wir tun das
jetzt schon mal und ich freue mich dass
heute morgen bei uns sind nina scheer
die klimaschutz und energiepolitische
sprecherin der spd-fraktion und andreas
jung ist bei uns in derselben funktion
in der unions fraktion tätig guten
morgen ihnen beiden schön dass sie da
sind
der wirtschaftsminister habe spricht von
der wisag der größten energiepolitischen
gesetzesnovelle seit jahrzehnten in
einer hinsicht recht israel
gesetzentwürfe sind fast 600 seiten
stark was den umfang angeht habe ich
gelesen was frau her ist aus ihrer sicht
der entscheidende punkt unter ziemlich
vielen die wir jetzt alle auflisten
könnten entscheidende punkt ist dass wir
die vielen sich angestaut haben den
hemmnisse bei der energiewende die auch
regulativ sind also auch in den gesetzen
verankert sind dass diese abgebaut
werden und dass wir auch von den
ausgegangenen mengen die wir an strom
brauchen für zwanzig dreißig dass wir da
eine anpassung vornehmen weil wir im
jahr 2030 deutlich mehr strom brauchen
der alleine mit blick auf die
verkehrswende auf die wärme wende die
sehr viel mehr strom enthalten wird wenn
man davon immer zu niedrigen zahlen
ausgeht und davon wiederum einen anteil
erneuerbarer energien erreichen möchte
der dann auch noch zu niedrig angesetzt
ist wie es in der vergangenheit immer
waren dann brauchen wir uns nicht zu
wundern wenn die ausbau mengen die
förderinstrumente und alles was da dran
hängt immer zu wenig waren in der
vergangenheit dann kamen noch weitere
hemmnisse administrativer art dazu wir
wollen hier mit einem großen kraftakt
diese ganzen hemmnisse diese ganzen die
beschleunigung hemmenden faktoren
beseitigen um so ein bisschen
plastischer zu machen sagen sie ein
konkretes beispiel für die hemmnisse die
sie jetzt wiederholt erwähnt haben wir
wissen zum beispiel dass bei der
windenergie
gerade wenn es um die akteure landwirte
kommunen und bürgerinnen und bürger die
kleineren akteure ging dass die sehr
schwer nur anteil haben konnten am
ausbau erneuerbarer weil sie zum
beispiel nicht so einfach an den
ausschreibungen teilnehmen konnte wir
werden jetzt erleichtern auch für bürger
energiegesellschaften dass sie außerhalb
von ausschreibungs angeboten einfach
ohne großen administrativen drum herum
da jetzt in uni in die in die
beteiligung einsteigen können der union
herr jung insbesondere ihrem
wirtschaftsminister altmaier aus der
letzten legislaturperiode ist oft
vorgeworfen die energiewende verschleppt
zu haben insbesondere den ausbau was
windenergie angeht sie selber sind
bekanntermaßen ein befürworter eines
schnelleren ausbaus wie viel zustimmung
haben sie für diese drei für dieses
roster paket ich kann erst mal das
vorhergesagte teilen es geht in der tat
darum jetzt den ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien zu beschleunigen es geht darum
hemmnisse abzubauen
wo dafür vorschläge gemacht werden da
werden wir die mittragen wir erkennen
nur in diesem paket das auch neue hürden
aufgebaut werden sollen wenn zwei
beispiele es soll gedeckelt werden
die biomethan einspeisung in das gasnetz
gerade jetzt ist es aber doch wichtig
dass wir in biogasanlagen
produzierte energie in das gasnetz
einspeisen können weil wir doch alles
brauchen um russische energie zu
ersetzen dass es einen neuen deckel
geben das können wir nicht verstehen das
werden wir kritisieren in diesem
verfahren und ich mache ein zweites
beispiel ich hätte meine neue lage weil
sie ja auch gesagt haben das hat daher
oder die hemmnisse wie auch beschrieben
haben die frau schon erwähnt hat warum
haben sie den ich letzten
legislaturperiode schon abgeschafft dass
ein gelegen hat eine frage mit der wir
uns auseinandersetzen die richtet sich
an alle ein wesentlicher vorschlag ist
jetzt ein neuer vorschlag um erneuerbare
energien und augenschutz
zusammenzubringen wir haben in der tat
schon in der letzten legislaturperiode
die umweltminister aller länder über
jahre beraten ohne ein ergebnis zu haben
das übrigens eine ministerin der union
dabei gewesen und 11 der grünen und ein
paar andere das heißt die frage ist
berechtigt mit der müssen sich alle
beschäftigen geht es darum dass wir ein
möglichst breites bündnis ein möglichst
breiten schulterschluss um gemeinsam
voran zu gehen und da erwarten wir auch
vom
bundeswirtschaftsminister dass seine
reise durch die bundesländer jetzt nicht
folgenlos bleibt sind es auch
verhandlungen gibt mit den ländern um
gemeinsam zu einem ergebnis zu kommen
das darf nicht einfach vom bund aus
verordnet werden es muss gemeinsam
entwickelt werden in bayern ist ja schon
mal gewesen und er sieht ein kleines
bisschen so aus als wenn er ja auch ein
kleines bisschen da offenbar bewegt hat
beispielsweise was die entfernung angeht
von windrädern von sie von siedlungen
eingesetzt ich geb ich biete ihnen eine
frage an
gesetze sind das eine in der überleitung
auch schon gesagt irgendwie die frage
ist ja lässt sich das alles so umsetzen
wo sind sie denn die größten hürden im
moment noch darf ich noch mal ganz kurz
auf jahren eingehen weil das wir hier
irgendwo bei den erneuerbaren bei
welcher auch immer deckeln würden das
halte ich für ein grobes gerücht was das
macht es weil diese ja aber wir sind im
parlamentarischen verfahren ab heute und
wenn die entwürfe deckelungen enthalten
dann ist das jedenfalls nicht in unserem
sinne deswegen müssen wir schauen dass
wir das im einklang mit allen
rahmenbedingungen die wir auch
europarechtlich zu beurteilen haben und
zu bewerten einzubeziehen haben das
hinkriegen aber dass eine deckelung der
erneuerbaren am ende rauskommt das ist
nicht unser plan in bei der bioenergie
muss man aber zudem auch darauf achten
dass man sie möglichst verbessert
einsetzt ja deswegen dass man
veränderungen vornimmt ist so sehr wohl
sinnvoll weil man eben teilweise die
wertvolle bioenergie so eingesetzt hat
dass sie nicht ihren ihren charakter der
des allseits verfügbaren und
einsetzbaren auch als regelenergie die
einsetzbar wenn man keinen wind hat
keine sonne hat dass man sie gezielt
dort einsetzt und nicht einfach nur
stumpf verstromung dass man eben diesen
charakter der bioenergie besser
aufgreifen kann und dass man das auch
gesetzlich
stichwort flexibilisierung da auch mit
einbezieht aber beim bei windenergie was
haben wir da jetzt schon erreicht
umfasst von wegen was heißt mitnehmen
der länder es gibt auch einen
entwurf aus eine formulierungshilfe die
uns schon im parlament erreicht hat die
aber jetzt heult nicht eingebracht wird
was sehr bedauerlich finden dass man
auch diese leider in der letzten
koalition
eingebrachten 1000 meter abstand
möglichkeiten von windenergie zu
gebäuden ja die länder haben eine
möglichkeit bekommen diese 1000 meter
fix zu definieren das ist natürlich auch
ein hemmnis ja wir hätten es gerne
gehabt dass man diese 1000 meter wieder
beseitigt also dass man diese
möglichkeit diese abstände wieder
beseitigt weil die bundesländer ebenda
so fixe abstände machen können bayern
hat jetzt nicht einfach die 10h regelung
also diese zehn mal die höhe der
windkraftanlagen
regelungen abgeschafft sondern hat sich
auf diese 1000 meter regelung jetzt
nochmal bezogen also auch da haben wir
leider ein signal von länderseite dass
man nicht überall gewillt ist nicht
überall gewählt ist tatsächlich auf
solche abstände zu verzichten wir
brauchen wenn wir einen solchen konsens
wollen in den ländern da brauchen wir da
mehr bereitschaft auf länderseite dass
man auch pauschale abstandsregelung
verzichtet sonst muss einfach eine
bundesregelung her die solche pauschalen
abstände vermeidet soll ich kommen wir
nicht weiter junge gerne direkt dazu ich
finde was wir brauchen ist eine
vereinbarung von bund und ländern wo man
sich verständigt über die ziele was
müssen wir erreichen wie viel strom
produktion wie viel energie wie viel
wärme brauchen wir aus erneuerbaren
energien da sollten sich die länder dazu
kometen dafür ist die bereitschaft auch
da und der weg wie es dann in den
einzelnen ländern erreicht wird da haben
wir föderale vielfalt die gilt auch zu
berücksichtigen da brauchen wir auch die
regionen die ganzen planungsprozesse
die regionalverbände deshalb wünschen
wir uns dass in diesem prozess die
regionalplanung gestärkt wird weil sie
den möglichkeit bietet die ziele
verbindlich festzuschreiben und
gleichzeitig ausgleich zu schaffen mit
anderen belangen und das müssen wir
hinbekommen zielerreichung und akzeptanz
haben sie ja im vorfeld kritisiert dass
der bund zu viele vorgaben macht statt
auch im vorfeld schon mal mit den
ländern zu reden auf der anderen seite
muss man ja doch wahrscheinlich sagen
ohne vorgaben würde sich überhaupt
nichts bewegen wir müssen ja nur in die
vergangenen jahre zurück
ich hätte ja gerade beschrieben dass es
richtig ist dass die umweltminister in
ihren beratungen alleine nicht zu einem
ergebnis gekommen sind müssen jetzt alle
eint ihr verbundener vorgabe man da geht
es um wind und sonne bei der sonne
wünschen wir uns dass neben dem es im
eeg geregelt wird ist eine ganz einfache
botschaft gibt nämlich dass es für die
privaten dachanlagen steuerfreiheit gibt
es ist ein anreiz zu machen es sind
beitrag zum bürokratieabbau es gibt
einen vorschlag dazu auch aus dem
bundesrat um wirklich da einen boom
einschub eine freude auch zu erhalten
und auszulösen und eine bemerkung ein
zweiter deckel wird gemacht bei der
wasserkraft in dem oster paket ist das
vdi wasserkraft da wird ein deckel
eingezogen eine modernisierungs deckel
das halten wir für einen fehler wir
brauchen die ganze seite und da gehört
auch die wasserkraft seien
die erneuerbaren bekommen das ist klar
und es ist auch in der tat so wir
brauchen die vereinfachung gerade bei
der photovoltaik bei denen das hatte ich
ganz zu anfang ja schon gesagt bei all
dem was die bürgerinnen und bürger
sofort machen können da gibt es viel zu
viele hemmnisse ist dauert heutzutage
teilweise länger eine schon installierte
photovoltaikanlage abgenommen zu
bekommen als sie zu installiert auch
dass ein hemmnis was nicht sein muss
diese vereinfachen brauchen wir aber
auch da muss man ich will jetzt nicht
nach in die vergangenheit treten noch
mal aber leider dafür haben wir auch
hemmnisse aufgebaut in den letzten
jahren die jetzt mit sichtlicher abbauen
müssen und ich möchte nur davor warnen
zu lange sich nur auf runde tische zu
verlassen wir brauchen auch an manchen
stellen klärungen definitionen damit man
verlässlichkeit hat rechtssicherheit hat
dass auch die länder sie dann etwas
orientieren können um was die länder
brauchen ist unterstützung auch bei der
personellen bewältigung in den behörden
da haben wir glaube ich alle samt eine
verantwortung dass das keine jahre
langen genehmigungsverfahren gibt es
kann nicht sein dass eine
windkraftanlage mehrere jahre in der
genehmigungs schleife hängt da müssen
wir beschleunigt vorankommen und da
helfen dann irgendwann auch nun
unbegrenzt runde tische es muss das ziel
klar sein wir müssen hier tatsächlich
die den ausbau der erneuerbaren bei der
photovoltaik vervielfachen weil der
windenergie haben wir zur zeit auch ein
stagnieren dadurch dass wir zwar
ausbauen es werden weitere genehmigungen
erteilt aber zugleich werden ja auch
anlagen stillgelegt und das hält sich
teilweise zurzeit die waage oder ist
sogar rückläufig perspektivisch das darf
nicht sein wir brauchen auch mit
deutlichen vereinfachung für das
repowering also wird den ersatz alter
anlagen durch neue und darf nicht
kompliziert in neue
genehmigungsverfahren gehen das muss
eine selbstverständlichkeit sein das
repowering anzugehen der junge noch mal
dazu es hat von runden tischen gar nicht
gesprochen sind von echten zur handlung
die reise und die gespräche sind das
eine das andere ist dass man sich
verständigt dass sie auch ein prozess
der geht ja über jahrzehnte diese
bundesregierung ist für vier jahre im
amt aber dieser prozess wird länger
gehen damit erlöse pläne einbezogen
werden da werden die regionen mehr rolle
spielen und deshalb muss verhandelt
werden dass man sich gemeinsam auf
grundlegende ziel auf instrumente am
besten dann auch gemeinsam auf gesetze
verständigt da brauchen wir keine runden
tisch wir brauchen echte verhandlungen
wo man zusammensitzt und gemeinsam in
der sache regelt die erneuerbaren
möchten wird 2030 zu 80 prozent
ausgebaut und diesem exklusiven keine
jahrzehnte sondern das sind jetzt nur
noch acht jahre und 80 prozent von
ungefähr 750 terawattstunden sind
ungefähr so viel wie wenn wir das
heutige den heutigen strombedarf von 100
prozent erneuerbar hätten ja der flasche
selbst nicht jahrzehnte sondern gut
erzählt ja selbst acht jahre gehen über
die anzahl dieser regierung hinaus und
für die gibt es keinen bestandsschutz
dem gesetzespaket und deshalb wäre es
gut wenn wir so wie wir es hier
debattieren
miteinander sprechen ich begrüße sehr
dass fascher sagt es ist es die
grundlage und wo es deckel in diesem
gesetz gibt können wir die gemeinsam ab
ich habe befürchtet dass wir natürlich
nur ansatzweise das erörtern können
worum es zugeht weil das natürlich wie
üblich alles viel komplizierter ist als
man sich vorstellen kann teufel steckt
ganz häufig im detail ich habe eine
frage die ich unbedingt noch loswerden
will erneuerbare energien sind das eine
auf der anderen seite frage ich mich
warum in diesen zeiten wo energie immer
teurer wird warum das thema
energiesparen
nicht mich größer gemacht wird warum es
keine kampagne gibt und zwar nicht im
hinblick zu sagen zieht euch im winter
ein pullover mehr an sondern einfach
richtig sinnvoll selbst der adac sagt
inzwischen seinen vereinsmitgliedern
gefallen fahrrad zum bäcker irgendwie
oder kombiniert meinetwegen fahrten
warum kommt er aus der politik ist das
echt in anführungszeichen warum kommt in
dem feld da einfach so wenig und das war
das einfachste und das günstigste und
sinnvoll in vielerlei hinsicht noch
einiges kommen also das dann wird es
auch informationskampagnen geben da bin
ich zuversichtlich dass da noch mehr
kommt und man muss eben einfach schauen
dass das auch ein solidarpakt ist es
darf nicht die kommunikation entstehen
fürs sparen sind jetzt einige wenige
zuständig auf der anderen seite wird
noch energie gebracht sondern das müssen
möglichst maßnahmen sein die in die
solidarisch von allen gleichermaßen eine
relative beeinflussung benachteiligung
einzelner gruppen stattfinden das ist
eine ganz wichtige angelegenheit beim
sparen aber natürlich wir haben enorme
einsparpotenziale auch solche die viele
menschen gar nicht so kennen deswegen
ist die information darüber immens
wichtig allein im gasbereich schätzt man
dass man ungefähr zehn prozent einsparen
könnte durch relativ einfache maßnahmen
das muss man ganz kurze antwort schaffen
noch teile des umfrage deshalb wo ist
endlich der energie sparplan der
bundesregierung wo ist die groß
angelegte kampagne für gas sparen wo ist
ein förderprogramm für
heizungsoptimierung - massenhaft gemacht
wird kann es einen wichtigen beitrag
leisten wo sind die vorschläge der
bundesregierung die in italien
öffentlichen gebäuden energie zu sparen
alles was wir jetzt sparen könnte
speichern und hilft im winter während
die entlassung ist genauso aus wie meine
werbeeffekt eine sommerrain gehen aber
es ist klar dass zur nächsten
heizperiode eine solche planung
angekommen sein und das ist allen klar
jetzt mal ganz fix aufhören weil die
bundestags präsidentin bärbel bas schon
an ihrem platz ich hatte gehofft wie sie
früher rein lassen zu können aber da
würden wir es so interessant vielen dank
frau scherer vielen dank herr jung und
ich gebe ganz fix rein